it's michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry phd
cosmetic chemist and sunscreen connoisseur
today we're doing an update of
my sunscreen recommendations
i usually do more beauty science videos hit the
nerdification bell for those when they upload
but everyone asks me about product
recommendations so here they are
but first a bunch of disclaimers because
i do not have the self-confidence to
give my opinion without them i am working on that
this list is obviously subjective
everyone has different likes and
dislikes so don't assume that
you'll just like all of these
it's a good idea to check out recommendations
from people with similar skin to you because
you'll probably like similar formulas i have
oily to normal skin it's prone to clogged pores
especially with sunscreens dehydration and
hyperpigmentation if you're not sure about
your skin type and conditions the lab muffin
guide to basic skincare ebook can help you out
it also talks about how to choose
and use products including sunscreen
white cast is a problem with a lot of sunscreens
my skin tone is nc20 if your skin is dark look
at reviews from people with a similar skin
tone to you to check that it won't show up
i like high uva protection because of
my hyperpigmentation which is genetic
my dad is basically a giant mole i have a
video on uva i prefer products with newer
filters because they usually feel lighter
i also like sunscreens that are formulated
to sit nicely and not bunch up under makeup
and make me look like i have face dandruff
also i'm australian but the vast majority of you
watching this are not so i'll be talking about
products that are and aren't approved as proper
therapeutic sunscreens in australia the ones that
are will have a listing number also for australian
sunscreens spf 50 plus actually means above spf 60
things work differently here
we ride kangaroos in pairs
because public transport there was an emu war
also different sunscreens are formulated
for different purposes so for example
most popular asian sunscreens are only meant for
going to the office so they might not hold up to
dancing in the rain or eating a really spicy laksa
for moist activities you probably want to
look for a water resistant sunscreen instead
it's also good to avoid roasting in the sun even
with sunscreen on and to layer your protection use
sun protective clothing hats and sunglasses
even if you try really hard you're probably
not getting a perfect layer of sunscreen so
if you have a few other types of protection
you'll probably still get good protection overall
your swiss cheese holes are unlikely to line up
and for all of these you'll want to be applying
around a quarter teaspoon for your face half a
teaspoon for face neck and ears check out my
sunscreen questions video for more about how
to use sunscreen all of these products were given
to me as pr samples or as part of a sponsorship
but 95% of the sunscreens i've been given haven't
made it onto this list so i do have standards
all right let's **** up some sunscreens
okay so for legal reasons i have to say this is a
joke do not drink your sunscreens follow
the instructions like a normal human being
the la roche posay anthelios
invisible fluid facial sunscreen
this is also commonly called the shaka fluid
this is my partner's favorite sunscreen
this one it meets all the marks of my
favorite sunscreen because uh it's nice
and thin nice screw top here i'm not afraid of
it exploding my backpack this this is the goods
this is a very lightweight non-greasy
sunscreen designed for sensitive skin
and it's pretty much invisible after you apply
it it's fragrance free absorbs easily into skin
doesn't clog pores and sits nicely under makeup
it's just a comfortable daily sunscreen it's also
formulated to not sting eyes and that seems to
be true for most people who have reviewed this
eye sting seems to vary a lot though
and so far i don't think there's any
real pattern with which ingredients sting or
not it changes a lot from person to person
the packaging is also really nice the liquid
texture in this packaging with the small dropper
opening also means there's less product wastage
unless your partner decides to apply it to his
back one day for no apparent reason because some
of us are unable to function in polite society
there's a very similar looking product in
the us so be careful check the ingredients
to make sure you're buying the australian
and european version with the newer filters
biore uv aqua rich watery essence this
is the 2019 version which as of right now
is the newest version sort of there's a 2021 light
up version with a white cast on purpose which is
actually a common thing with asian
sunscreen so check which one you're buying
this one doesn't have a white cast and it's
one of the most popular asian sunscreens
the watery essence line is famous for having this
really nice and light fresh non-sticky feeling on
your face it's designed to work as a foundation
primer as well although it can peel a little bit
with some foundations i'm guessing it's because
it's water resistant water resistant sunscreens
tend to peel a bit more because of the extra film
forming ingredients that help them stay in place
this says it's 80 minutes water resistant
from what i can tell there's no official
water resistance standard in japan and there
are a bunch of different standards around
the world so it's hard to work out exactly
how water resistant it is after 80 minutes
but it is one of the lightest least pilly
water-resistant sunscreens out there
alcohol is quite high on the ingredients
list which generally isn't a problem because
this has a lot of moisturizing ingredients as
well to balance out any drying alcohol isn't
necessarily bad in skincare i have a video
that goes through all the evidence on that
but some people can have
issues with it so if that's you
this might not be the best option but a lot of
people with sensitive skin do love this sunscreen
it also has a mild floral scent
once the alcohol smell goes away
the biggest downside to this sunscreen and
a lot of japanese sunscreens in general
is that they tend to reformulate them every
couple of years which makes it really confusing
to work out which one you're buying and which
one people are reviewing but it's great from a
technology point of view this version was
updated with encapsulated uv filters that
they call the micro defense system it helps the
sunscreen form a more continuous film on skin
beauty of joseon relief sun rice and probiotics
is a korean sunscreen and it's currently the
sunscreen i've been recommending the most i
know some people are a bit skeptical about
korean sunscreens but this is manufactured
by kolmar who are widely recognized as the
top korean sunscreen producer the spf has been
certified by two labs in two different countries
and it's actually approved as a sunscreen in korea
which is not the case with all korean sunscreens
so this is probably one of the
most legit korean sunscreens
it's really lightweight with a
non-sticky moisturizing finish
similar to a light moisturizer even if you
apply lots of it it doesn't clump up or get
cakey under makeup there's no white cast on
light and medium skin but i have seen it show
up on darker skin it has no fragrance and no
alcohol if those are problems for your skin
the only issue is that this is designed
to be lightweight and wash off easily so
if you're sweaty or moving around a lot very
vigorously eating a spicy laksa this probably
won't be as appropriate but it's great as an
everyday sunscreen maybe for a mild laksa day
in terms of skincare ingredients it
has rice extracts which are meant
to be great for hydration and for sensitive skin
there's glycerin which is also great for
hydration there's niacinamide and adenosine
which are brightening and anti-wrinkle ingredients
used in a lot of korean functional cosmetics
isntree hyaluronic acid airy sun stick is a new
entry to my list this really intrigued me because
this is the sunscreen that isntree recommend
for oily and combination skin and to me sticks
have always been on the heavy side but i think
i have to change my opinion this is extremely
light and non-sticky it glides on super smoothly
and is designed to not clump up even over makeup
the stick has a droplet shape that's designed
to make it easier to apply on the curves of
your face so next to your nose and around your
eyes like the beauty of joseon sunscreen it's
made by kolmar and is properly approved in
korea it also has niacinamide and adenosine
and is approved as a brightening and
anti-wrinkle functional cosmetic in korea
it also has eight types of hyaluronic
acid in it which means there are lots of
different molecular sizes which can
sink into skin at different depths
and give more well-rounded hydration there's
also a bunch of antioxidants and ceramide
the biggest downside this is very small 22 grams
which is less than half the size of the watery
sun gel which is another isntree sunscreen
that's coming up in my recommendations spoiler
but it's more expensive as well it's also a bit
tricky to be confident about how
much of a stick you need to apply
the aad website recommends four swipes but i'm
not really sure how they came up with that number
i think sticks are really useful though they
usually have waxy ingredients that tend to stay
put on skin a bit better than a lot of lotions so
if you have a great sunscreen that burns your eyes
try using a stick around your eyes and putting
the stinging sunscreen on the rest of your face
you can also layer a translucent powder on
top to try to keep it in place even more
the neutrogena sheer zinc stick is another great
option for this i think if you get a lot of eye
sting a zinc stick is probably your safest option
on top of the benefits of having a stick you also
avoid chemical sunscreens some of those can cause
a lot of sting although i also know some people
who only get stinging with mineral sunscreens
like i said eye sting is just all over the place
ultra violette supreme screen is an australian
sunscreen that's their all-rounder product meant
for all skin types it's hydrating so it doubles
up as a moisturizer but has a satin finish and
works well as a primer under makeup it has
what they describe as a clean sort of scent
and it has a bunch of antioxidants in it as well
and it has my favorite type of sunscreen packaging
a pump top they're just so handy and it makes
it easy to remember how much you need to use
i really love that ultra violette sunscreens were
developed by women who have a lot of experience
making products for a multi-step
routine so their sunscreens tend to
work well for morning routines where the
sunscreen might need to be layered with
other skincare and makeup products some brands
don't really seem to take that into account and
you end up looking like your skin is kind
of falling off which is not the nicest look
but the whole ultra violette line
was purposely designed to play
well with other products so i think
that's why they've gotten so popular
as well as australia you can get ultra
violette in a whole bunch of uk retailers
they have a few other really popular sunscreens
too like the queen screen which is for dry skin
the cancer council face day wear
fluid is another new entry on my list
it's another western lightweight
fluid sunscreen launched late 2021
i think they might have been inspired by
the la roche-posay fluid it's a bit more
affordable though so it hurts less if someone
decides to empty half the bottle on their back
it comes in a handy pump which also makes it more
likely that you'll catch them before that happens
it's recommended for combo and oily skin
absorbs quickly dries smoothly on skin
and has a few mattifying ingredients
in terms of eye sting people have said
that it stings less than some of the
other cancer cancer sunscreens
like the face day wear matte
but it can still sting so be warned i think
my favourite thing about it is that it funds
the cancer council who do a lot of cancer
research and provide cancer related services
mecca recently-ish reformulated
their to save face sunscreen
look the last few years old just one big blur
i think it was late 2020 the old version was
super popular in australia so this is the new
version it's been designed to copy the original
all the inactive ingredients are the same but it
does have slightly different filters they got rid
of oxybenzone which isn't that bad an ingredient
really but it's the sunscreen active that gets
all the blame it's like the jar jar binks of
sunscreen ingredients and it's actually quite
rare to see oxybenzone in australian sunscreens
so i'm guessing that's why they changed it
so they took oxybenzone out and added
bemotrizinol also called tinosorb s which
is a newer photostable filter that's mostly used
to boost uva protection it's one of my favorite
sunscreen ingredients mecca is a beauty store in
australia a lot like sephora so their sunscreen
was purposely designed with makeup wearers in
mind it's lightweight and non-greasy and sits
under foundation really nicely it has a pretty
matte finish and has some moisturizing ingredients
and antioxidants like sodium pca vitamin e and
pycnogenol it has a moderately strong floral scent
and a few people on the mecca website have said
that it stings their eyes so watch out for that
one really good thing about this is that there's
a mini 30 gram version as well as this 75 gram one
so you can test it out thoroughly if you're in
australia you can also just go
into the store and try it on
ultraceutical's mattifying daily moisturizer is
the daily sunscreen that i've been recommending
for the longest it's a mattifying sunscreen that
absorbs quickly there are silica microspheres in
it that absorb excess skin oil and diffuse
light to give a matte look which is why it's
recommended for oily skin but it also
has a lot of moisturizing ingredients
in it like my favorite glycerin as
well as shea butter hyaluronic acid
panthenol and niacinamide to give
a boost of moisture to your skin
it doesn't clog pores it sinks into
skin quickly and there's no whiteness
it comes in a handy pump tube over the last
five-ish years i've been recommending this
sunscreen a lot of people have asked
me about the relatively low spf 30.
i think spf 30 is fine for everyday
use if you're not getting a lot of sun
especially if you can apply a lot of it
comfortably since spf depends on the amount
the biggest sunscreen study that
discovered a lot of the anti-aging
and anti-cancer benefits of daily
sunscreen was done using spf 16
in the sunniest part of australia their kangaroo
pouches actually have air con now but it does feel
a bit low since everything else on the market
is usually at least spf 50 now so i was pretty
happy to see that there's now an spf 50 version
and it looks like it has similar ingredients the
reviews i've seen are very promising there
is also a hydrating version for drier skin
ultraceuticals products are on the expensive
end but i don't mind as much because they're
a smaller brand and they do a lot of
clinical testing and original research
for example they published this paper which is one
of the most heavily cited and ripped off papers
about vitamin c if you see a table about vitamin
c derivatives they probably got it off this
so the money is going to something better than
i don't know paying a celebrity to endorse it
this is a special use sunscreen i wanted
to mention the naked sundays hydrating glow
mist this is what i recommend for a quick
sunscreen top up over your makeup this is
a pump spray rather than an aerosol spray i've
talked before about why i don't like aerosols
and it has pretty detailed instructions
on how to apply it which i really like
i have seen some people say that their
spray packaging started leaking after
they had it in their bag for a bit but that
hasn't happened to mine this is non-sticky
non-greasy has a bunch of hydrating ingredients
in it and says it doesn't need to be rubbed in
a spray wouldn't be my top choice
for reapplication if you're getting
a lot of sun i'd recommend a proper
reapplication of a regular lotion product
you can check out my sunscreen
questions video for more about that
now let's have a moment of silence for the
sunscreens that have exited my
recommendations since last year
anessa perfect uv milk the 2020 version was on my
list but i haven't tried the newest 2022 version
which has a blue label and currently is even more
expensive than the 2020 version the old one was a
bit heavy in texture for an asian sunscreen but
it worked really nicely under makeup with no
pilling despite being water resistant people said
that the new version is a bit heavier and shinier
i can also confirm that the canmake mermaid
gel was reformulated in 2020 i think there
were still some tubes of the old version
floating around when i did my last video
but the new version apparently has more
of a white cast and it's a bit more drying
azclear action day moisturizer also
got reformulated and i haven't tried
the new version yet but i've
heard it's quite different
now for some honorable mentions
isntree watery sun gel is what i recommend if
you have drier skin and you found that asian
sunscreens aren't necessarily moisturizing enough
this has a heavier texture and is designed for
dry and sensitive skin it's been clinically
tested to not irritate skin there's no white
cast no fragrance and no alcohol this hits on
a lot of the same points as the airy sun stick
manufactured by kolmar approved in korea
brightening and anti-wrinkle functional cosmetic
with niacinamide and adenosine multi-layered
hydration from eight types of hyaluronic acid
the spf and pa ratings have
also been independently tested
isntree recommends this for outdoor activities
but there's no official water resistance rating so
i probably wouldn't recommend it for hardcore
exercise or like doing push-ups while eating laksa
but it might be a bit more durable than
other korean sunscreens it's also recommended
for application over makeup i think a lot of
lightweight sunscreens are really good for this
i have a video on how to do that
if you want to check that out
also note that they introduced
new packaging for this which is
why it looks a bit different from the
tube you saw in my previous reviews
cancer council face day wear matte moisturizer
cancer council face day wear matte has
a lightweight easy to apply texture it's
moisturizing gives a matte finish on skin
and it's fragrance free this is the
invisible version it's really popular
it won an award from the website beauty heaven
it's quite affordable at $15 for 75 grams
here is the filter combo i'm quite surprised
that it uses avobenzone as the only uva filter
since we do have newer ones available
here but the fluid which has bemt and
mbbt was only launched last year so
maybe they're rolling them out gradually
it seems to be a similar formula to the aldi ombra
daily defence and the natio daily defence they all
have the same filters at the same percentages
as well as the same inactive ingredients
on the topic of this sunscreen i wanted to
also shout out the face day wear bb cream matte
in the light tint which i love
this is technically a cosmetic
sunscreen in australia rather than
a proper therapeutic sunscreen so
it isn't regulated as strictly but sunscreens
are cosmetics in a lot of other countries
this seems to be a very similar formula to the
matte moisturizer based on the ingredients list
but it's tinted and it's lightly tinted enough
that you can apply a full sunscreen sized amount
but still look normal and this actually makes
my skin look so nice and still so natural
but it stings my eyes i think
it's the sunscreen actives combo
i actually liked it so much that i kept trying
it for a full week i was in so much denial
but i've also seen lots of reviews of this
where people didn't have this issue so
i think there's some luck involved so this
is perfect for the sunscreen stick trick
just for australians or if you're visiting
australia i'd recommend trying the woolworths
coles and aldi $2.20 sunscreens they're
ridiculously cheap and they're much more
lightweight than a lot of more expensive
sunscreens i've tried they leave a shiny
sticky finish but you can powder over that to
get rid of it and they're also four hours water
resistant and if you don't like them on your face
then you can use them on your body they're super
comfortable there too some councils actually give
out free tubes of these in the public kangaroos
i also wanted to mention evy evy are a swedish
brand sold in the eu and they use technology
that gets the sunscreen to lock into the
top layers of skin so it doesn't rub off
as easily it's very cool i've talked about the
data backing up their longwear claims before
now for my us viewers you always
ask me for recommendations that
you can actually buy in your stores
but your country hasn't approved a
lot of the newer sunscreen ingredients
that are basically standard in australia
and these ingredients make it a lot easier to
formulate high protection sunscreens that are
still really lightweight and comfortable to
wear but you do have a few that i'd recommend
bondi sands fragrance free lotion was developed
and approved in australia so it meets our higher
standard for broad spectrum which is the same as
the one in the eu the us has a lower standard so a
lot of sunscreens that count as broad spectrum
in the us don't count as broad spectrum here
this is a fast absorbing sunscreen and it's four
hours water resistant you can get it in the uk
as well and it had a big moment on social
media where everyone was raving about it
and that sort of highlighted to me
how lucky we are in australia to have
so many good brands working on great
sunscreens from the ingredients list
the face and body versions look
like they might be the same formula
elta md uv clear is a new entry on my list it's
probably the most popular elta md sunscreen elta
md is a brand that's sold in a lot of skin
clinics it's very lightweight and silky it's
meant to be good for sensitive skin including
skin prone to acne and rosacea and it applies
clear with no residue i'm not entirely sure it
would meet the broad spectrum requirements for
australia or the eu with its filters
but it is broad spectrum in the us
and it's very wearable so if you're not getting
a lot of sun this is a pretty good option
mineral sunscreens that use titanium dioxide
or zinc oxide as the sunscreen ingredients
usually have white cast and a thick paste
like texture that sticks to my fringe
especially when you get to higher spf which i
really don't like they also often clog my pores
i have a whole video where i just complain
about zinc oxide because i don't know
i woke up one day and decided to piss off half the
beauty brands that might potentially sponsor me
i'm not that smart i just
play a smart person on youtube
anyway some people prefer using mineral
sunscreens maybe they don't have
access to the newer chemical filters that are
recommended for sensitive skin some people
actually like the white cast or the slightly
drying effect so here are my recommendations
ultra violette lean screen and naked sundays
collagen glow both are spf 50+ here which
means over spf 60 and paula's choice super
light daily wrinkle defense which is spf 30
all of these are fragrance free and
have a tint to help hide that white
cast they still aren't entirely
invisible on darker skin though
for very dark skin you're going to
need a chemical or combo sunscreen
if you want high protection without the white cast
i don't think there's a high spf mineral sunscreen
on the market that's completely invisible yet
all the links are in the description
comment with other sunscreens for me to try
like and subscribe follow me more sunscreen
videos are popping up around me if you want more